in this rna-seq demo pipeline we will
learn how we can generate rna gene
expression tables from the raw rna
secrets
you will see a menu of areas of analysis
or data types that you can process in
the transcriptomic section on the upper
left there is a drop down on the right
side of the rna seq chip option
if you click on this drop down it will
show you three demo pipeline options the
first step in your analysis is to choose
a pipeline here we are choosing the rnsc
pipeline associated with the patient
derived xenograft project in this
project we have mainly two breast cancer
subtypes
that is estrogen receptor positive and
triple negative
to begin this pipeline click on demo
rna-seq pdx project
after you are done clicking you will get
the interface with the pipeline
after clicking the start you will get a
pop-up to load the input files by
clicking ok
since this is a demo pipeline the files
will be automatically uploaded
once you start your pipeline the next is
pre-processing of raw reads here we are
performing two pre-processing steps
removal of adapters and removal of pcr
duplicates
during the rna sequencing process
adapters are attached to the reads in
this pipeline the trimomatic module
remove those adapters when you click on
trimomatic option you will get a pop-up
with the details
all you need to do is just click ok
once the dramomatic step is completed
the next pre-processing step is pcr
clean which will get highlighted
in this pipeline the pcr clean module
removes those adapters
once you pre-process and clean the raw
sequencing reads
next step is the mapping of these reads
on the reference genome or the
transcriptome
thus the mapping tools will get
highlighted
here we are using bauti 2t
tool to map the reeds
bounty 2t
is a version of the bounty 2 algorithm
configured to run mapping on transcripts
defined in the gtf file
once you click on the bauti 2t option
you will get a pop-up with the ok option
click on ok will complete the mapping
once you are able to map your reads on
the reference genome next step is the
quantification of rna expression values
there are different methods for rna
expression quantification like sailfish
rsem htsec etc
here in our demo pipeline we are using
the rsem or rsemx
expression table method that will
produce an rna expression table with
fpkm value
the rsem stands for rna-seq using
expectation maximization that is a
software package for quantifying gene
and isoform abundances from single end
or paired and rnse data
thus click on the rsem exp table that
will be highlighted in a yellow color
our same exp table is a script that will
generate an expression table based on
the output of boutique 2t
the script is an adaptation of the rsem
algorithm by clicking on the rsim exp
table option you will get a pop-up with
the ok option
by clicking on the ok option you will be
able to quantify rna expression
once quantification of the expression is
completed next to complete the pipeline
you will need to check the end option
present on the top of the right side
of the interface
once you click on the end option you
will get a pop-up with ok
by clicking on the ok option you will be
able to complete your pipeline
as this is a demo pipeline the results
will be showcased on the spot
the output files labeled with the fbkm
contain expression measurements in fbk
whereas the other simply contain the
count of reads per g or isoform
the files labeled with not filtered txt
contain genes with zero expression for
all samples whereas those genes are
filtered out in the other files
recall from previous lesson that boutin
can output tables of the expression
levels of all genes or a table of only
those genes expression above zero for
most applications we will only be
interested in those genes with
expression above zero further it is
computationally much more expensive when
dealing with large data sets to open a
table including zero expression level
genes
therefore we will practice using the
table of only those genes with
expression
in other words a table in which genes
with expression is equal to 0 have been
removed besides iso from expression file
to look at isoforms
open the gene expression file to look at
the genes
to interpret the results obtained you
can visit the omex logic learn portal
and go through the course